there was a big fight the other night
in which a giant hulking ex-special
forces dude
beat a woman beat her up
a giant hulking dude beat up a chick and
this was considered a great victory and
people applauded for that the fella's
name is alana mclaughlin i don't know
what his real name is but the name he
goes by is alana mclaughlin
he is the second openly transgender
woman
a dude to to beat up women in the mma
and he won his debut on friday night via
submission at the com combat global
preliminary games in miami
he's 38 years old he used a rear choke
hold against celine provost
ended the match 3 minutes 32 seconds
into the second round here's what he
said he goes i want to pick up the
mantle that fallon put down
fallon fox is another dude who went into
the ring to beat up women and cracked
open a woman's skull and people
applauded for that too they said yeah
yeah buddy you go you co-crack that
woman's skull equality freedom
he did that
he became the first uh transgender woman
to fight in the mma in 2012 and then
this fella says right now i'm following
in fallon's footsteps i'm just another
step along the way and it's my great
hope that there are more to follow
behind me
freedom right in this freedom this is
this is freedom according to the modern
liberal definition that many people on
the right
have bought into well it's his it's his
it's his freedom
if he feels like a woman then he gets to
just pretend to be a woman he gets he
gets to be treated as a woman he gets to
dress up like a woman and compete in
women's sports it's his freedom and by
the way the woman that he beat up
she agreed to do it
right let's not let's not make her into
a victim here i mean sure a hulking
special forces dude
just bruised her up but
she agreed to do it it was her consent
just like the woman who had her skull
cracked open by fallon fox she consented
to it
so it's her freedom too and look we're
all consenting
to watch this sick sick match
right this psychopathy in a ring and so
it's all it's all free it's all good as
long as you agree to it isn't that great
the heroin addict just decides to shoot
up you you tyrants better not tell him
that he can't shoot up a bunch of dope
and kill himself why that's his freedom
right
right no i don't think so
researchers have determined that email
phishing attacks and brute force attacks
are the two most popular and successful
methods that cyber criminals use for
ransomware and extortion attacks on
corporate networks these attacks are
very simple to attempt they're very
difficult to detect and they can come
with huge rewards for cyber criminals
good thing there's a lifelock it seems
today every week you read another story
about some huge cyber attack protect
yourself and your data lifelock helps
detect a wide range of identity threats
for instance your social security number
for sale on the dark web if they detect
that your information's potentially been
compromised they will send you an alert
you've got to protect your information i
know you think no one's after your
information no they're after
some famous guys information they're
after some big but they're after your
information okay
a
ounce of prevention is worth a pound of
cure here now no one can prevent all
identity theft or monitor all
transactions at all businesses but you
can keep what's yours with lifelock by
norton join now and save up to 25 off
your first year by going to lifelock.com
knowles that is lifelock.com
knowles for 25
off
what we saw happen i didn't watch it
obviously
but
what other people saw happen at the mma
is the refutation
of feminism
transgenderism
the whole sexual revolution and this
whole misunderstanding of liberty okay
feminism says men and women are exactly
the same they're identical there's some
superficial differences
but beyond superficial differences
they're identical and that's just not
true men and women are different they're
different physically they're different
emotionally they're different
ontologically
they're just different okay
a woman needs a man like a fish needs a
bicycle according to the feminists just
not true
men and women both need one another
transgenderism is the logical
consequence of feminism
if men and women are exactly the same
well first first then you're gonna have
to redefine marriage because men and
women are exactly the same so the union
of two men and the union of two women
has to be by just following that logic
it has to be the exact same as the union
between a man and a woman and then
following that logic a man can be a
woman and a woman can be a man because
there's actually no difference
right except
when they get into the ring and the men
crack the women's skulls open and then
you realize oh wait there is a
difference
ah no but i'm but i was told there is no
so i get i must be imagining this it
must be an illusion it was just the luck
of the draw that fallon fox cracked that
chick's skull open right it was just
it could have gone the other way the
chick could have cracked his skull open
except they never do because men and
women are different
the whole sexual revolution
do men and women relate to sex in the
same way
i don't think so
when a guy when a single guy goes out
with his buddies and they want to get up
to no good they are thinking about sex
in a different way than women are that's
just a fact leon cass the bioethicist
has this idea
it's called the wisdom of repugnance he
said there are certain things that just
at a gut level
we just
we just find icky okay and this is not
fully reliable to our understanding of
moral problems but
it is somewhat reliable think of incest
consensual incest where there is no
possibility of producing a child
right there you can't really make a
utilitarian argument for why that's a
bad thing because there won't be a child
there won't be any extra now these two
people are consenting they love each
other it's no big deal and yet
we just have this aversion to it we just
think that's just
there's something wrong about it there's
something wrong about a man cracking a
woman's skull open
and
if you're if you're bought into the
logic of liberalism and progressivism
and all these modern ideologies you
can't really explain if you're a
conservative you can explain why it's
wrong but if you're a modern you can't
quite explain why it's wrong but you
know too
you know too
that it is wrong
[Music]
[Music]
you